[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute eine
Torte zum Ramadanfest also zum Bayram
oder bzw aid und das wird diesmal eine
ganz ganz hübsche Torte die ich mir so
in den Kopf gesetzt habe ich werde das
zusammen mit euch heute machen ich habe
das jetzt nicht vorab ausprobiert was
ich aber vorab natürlich schon gemacht
habe ist so ein bisschen Vorbereitung
wie zum Beispiel Biskuitboden und zwar
habe ich heute einfach mal meine fertige
Mischung genommen meine Biskuit Mix ihr
könnt aber auch auf meinen Biskuitboden
Rezept zugreifen ich schreibe euch alles
ganz genau hier unten in die Infobox
wenn ihr den Titel einmal auf habt
streckt sich dann so eine lange
Zutatenliste wo alles haarfein genau
steht damit ihr das nachmachen könnt wie
gesagt ich finde gerade jetzt wir sind
mitten im Ramadan ich bin noch am Fasten
es ist sowieso alles ein bisschen
anstrengender greife ich gerne auf die
Möglichkeit zurück ich habe
Biskuit Mixe genommen und dann in 22 cm
Tortenringe
gelegt glatt verstrichen und dann bei
Umluft 160 Grad für 40 Minuten gebacken
Infos stehen aber wie immer unten in der
Infobox was ich auch vorbereitet habe
sind buttercremes da habe ich heute eine
zitronenbuttercreme gemacht auch da gibt
es schon mein basic Rezept auf dem Kanal
also um dieses Video so kurzweilig wie
möglich zu gestalten und direkt ans
Eingemachte zu gehen habe ich das
einfach schon mal vorbereitet und dafür
sind ja auch diese basic Rezepte da
damit ihr da einfach drauf zugreifen
können ich schreibe euch aber unter
diesem Video die Mengen die ihr eben für
unsere heutige Torte benötigt also ich
habe jetzt hier meine drehbare
Tortenplatte ich habe jetzt hier auch
schon so ein cakeboard unten drunter
damit ich gleich auch gleich der
transportieren kann und jetzt nehme ich
einen der sechs Böden schon mal hier
drauf und ihr könnt jetzt wenn ihr
möchtet weil ich habe ja eine Zitronen
Buttercreme und ihr könnt auch
zitronenkrad also Lemon Curd auf den
Boden versprechen damit ihr noch mal
dieses diesen zitronigen voll Geschmack
habt ich habe mir halt gedacht wenn
schon Buttercreme weil das brauchen wir
für unser heutiges Projekt weil
Buttercreme halt super stabil wird dann
wenigstens eine die schön frisch
schmeckt zitronig ist und ich muss sagen
ich bin jetzt auch nicht so der aller
aller allergrößte Fan von Buttercreme
aber auf die Art wie ich das Rezept
mache da ist die Buttermenge reduziert
und es wird ebenso fluffig aufgeschlagen
das ist halt wirklich lecker schmeckt da
dürft ihr euch bitte nicht abschrecken
lassen so ich habe jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen Lemon Curd auf dem Boden
verteilt und gebe da jetzt helle
Buttercreme ich habe meine buttercremes
eingefärbt das heißt innen bleibt hell
und außen das kann ich Euch noch mal
zeigen richtig schöne Farbe
außen nehme ich dann in die Gruppe blau
so verlinke ich euch natürlich alles in
die Infobox wenn ihr da irgendwie Tools
oder Produkte sucht und jetzt ist halt
wichtig dass jetzt keine dicke Schicht
nimmt sondern eigentlich nur eine ganz
dünne Schicht und so starte ich das
ganze jetzt bis ich ganz oben angekommen
bin
[Musik]
so die Torte ist jetzt bis obenhin
geschichtet ganz oben habe ich einfach
den Boden genommen und umgedreht als
Deckel drauf gegeben dann ist so eine
schöne glatte Oberfläche und jetzt nehme
ich mir noch hier ich habe so einen
guten Esslöffel an Buttercreme noch
übrig ich hatte mir ein Drittel von der
gesamt Creme einfach noch beiseite
gelegt weil ich das hell haben wollte
und da versiegel ich jetzt einfach nur
ganz grob die Seiten und dann kommt das
für 15 bis 20 Minuten in den Kühlschrank
einfach damit jetzt ein bisschen fest
wird und wir weiter arbeiten können
so lasst euch von meinem Handy hier
vorne nicht stören ich werde das so ein
bisschen mit Film für tik tok und insta
wenn ihr mir dort noch nicht folgt holt
das sehr gerne nach und jetzt werden wir
den Kuchen zerschneiden ich habe mir
hier aus dem cakeboard einfach so eine
Mondsichel ausgeschnitten es könnte
einfach frei Schnauze machen und jetzt
müssen wir darauf achten wenn wir den
Kuchen der gleich umdrehen werden und
dann wird ein Teil vom Kuchen
abgeschnitten ihr werdet im Verlauf des
Videos sehen was ich genau meine müssen
wir jetzt darauf achten dass die Mond
sicher relativ weit oben platziert wird
aber auch nicht so weit oben dass der
Kuchen irgendwie einstürzt also ich muss
eigentlich die Idee ist jetzt gerade
wirklich nur in meinem Kopf und ich habe
das noch nicht ausprobiert und ich hoffe
einfach dass ich am Ende des Videos eine
schöne bayramtorte habe so und jetzt
fange ich an zu schneiden wo ich lieber
erst ein bisschen gröber die Feinheiten
kann man später noch mit der Buttercreme
machen und ihr kommt auch wahrscheinlich
nicht ganz bis zum Boden weil das ist
eine sehr hohe Torte daher schaut
einfach wie weit ihr kommt und wir die
Torte gleich noch umdrehen können wir da
noch den Rest ausschneiden
[Musik]
also es läuft viel viel besser als ich
es jemals vermutet hätte das hier wird
natürlich verwertet und das ist so krass
als ich das rausgeschnitten habe kam der
ganze Zitronengeruch wenn die Nase ich
habe eh das Gefühl dass wenn man fastet
die Sinne also wir sind jetzt am Tag
acht gerade wo wir das finden die Sinne
werden extrem gestärkt ich bin noch viel
konzentrierter aber ich hätte nicht
erwartet dass es so gut klappt so jetzt
nehme ich hier meine Indigo blaue
Buttercreme und werde also wir machen
mehrere Schichten erstmal werde ich
rundherum und innen ganz grob
einstreichen dann wird gekühlt und dann
wird wieder verstrichen
[Musik]
so ich hatte die Torte jetzt in der
Kühlung also ich habe Platz im
Gefrierfach deswegen war die jetzt bei
zehn Minuten im Gefrierfach ihr könnt
aber auch einfach 20 bis 25 Minuten in
den Kühlschrank stellen das geht auch so
und jetzt muss natürlich ein bisschen
schöner sein das war jetzt erstmal nur
ganz grob das war die krümelbindung und
jetzt geht's ans Eingemachte das heißt
jetzt so verstreichen dass ihr mit dem
Endergebnis zufrieden seid und alles
schön angleichen ich zeige euch gleich
noch mal den Trick mit Backpapier das
heißt einfach Backpapier oben drüber
legen und dann anschließend auch die
andere Seite bestreichen und das
Backpapier hilft ihm dass das auch noch
mal schön glatt bleibt
[Musik]
also ich habe jetzt noch mal umgedreht
weil die andere Seite die muss natürlich
auch mit Buttercreme bestrichen werden
und später kommt er auch wieder ein
Backpapier oben drauf und ein cakeboard
dann nehme ich aber mein Edelstahl
cakeboard weil das ist dann schwerer das
beschwert das ganze noch mal ein
bisschen und ich muss sagen mich
erinnert dieses dunkelblaue halt immer
ein Ramadan und ich habe ja schon zwei
Ramadan Torten die eine da ist äh ja
diese diese Puppe die dann was vom
Kuchen ist kann ich am einblenden und
das andere war auch mit einer Mondsichel
und auch in schönen Blautönen aber ein
bisschen heller fand ich auch mega cool
also wenn ihr noch Inspiration sucht ich
werde euch mal alle Ramadan Torten also
Torten bei dem Torten verlinken
die mich auch cool muss ich sagen da war
der Thema Baklava dann hatten wir noch
Pistazien im Teig also auch vom
Geschmack her hier bin ich ehrlich da
habe ich gedacht es muss ein geiler
Geschmack sein weil Zitrone mag einfach
jeder und ähm das so ein bisschen
ausgleichen dass ich halt diesen
fluffigen Boden habe gepaart mit dieser
Buttercreme und da sollte es
geschmacklich einfach klassisch und
lecker sein wenn die anderen auch lecker
aber hier ist der Geschmack halt einfach
super klassisch und ich gehe halt
wirklich davon aus dass jeder so ein
kleines Stückchen zu seinem Tee sich
gönnt und genießt
[Musik]
ich habe es nochmal kühlen lassen und
ich finde das sieht so samtig aus also
es kommt auf jeden Fall der Wald rüber
den ich haben wollte das freut mich und
jetzt schnappen wir uns ein scharfes
Messer und schneiden jetzt quasi ich bin
so doof ich muss noch kurz real Talk
betreiben hier ich habe hier ich die
ganze Zeit ach ja da ist noch eine
Stelle weiß aber das ist ja mein unten
das untere schneide ich hier weg dann
aber erst gesehen das ist ja die Seite
ist aber ich lasse es jetzt so ich finde
das gar nicht schlimm ich werde jetzt
hier gerade abschneiden denn die stürzen
dass er gleich auf die andere Seite das
heißt das ist gleich unser Boden könnt
euch das hier so vor markieren ich muss
noch immer in Richtung angucken kann ist
echt nach Augenmaß machen das ist
eigentlich wirklich easy ja so und da
schneide ich jetzt ab das ist dann auch
zu einem Rest aber den verwerten wir ich
mache gleich noch so schöne
eigentlich schon fast fertig
so jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich
wie bekomme ich jetzt die Torte
umgedreht auf die Platte ich habe jetzt
einfach so eine Schieferplatte also ich
würde euch raten
erstmal muss sie komplett gut
durchgekühlt sein ich hatte es jetzt
gerade auch noch mal für 10 Minuten in
der Kühlung und das tolle ist an dieser
Buttercreme dass sie wirklich schön fest
wird als nicht wirklich fest sondern
einfach angenehm fest und deswegen hatte
ich ja auch eingangs gesagt wir brauchen
eine Buttercreme in Kombination mit
diesem Böden für dieses Rezept weil
nicht nur Geschmack ist wichtig sondern
auch das ist schön stabil ist ich nehme
jetzt hier einfach mein Messer mit einer
Schere würde ich das glaube ich nicht so
gut dran kommen und versuche das
Backpapier unten nochmal abzuschneiden
weil ich glaube dass mich das gleich
stören wird ich habe hier oben auch noch
mal ein frisches Backpapier dran gegeben
äh dienen jetzt gleich einfach dazu dass
sich das besser anfassen kann man könnte
zwar auch die Torte so anfassen aber mit
Backpapier ist angenehmer so das kommt
jetzt weg ich habe jetzt noch ein
bisschen Buttercreme übrig das dient
jetzt hier noch mal so als Stabilisator
als Kleber also einfach hier drauf
verteilen
es ist echt schön wenn ein Plan aufgeht
muss ich echt sagen
so das platziere ich jetzt hier komplett
am Rand
okay und jetzt sind einfach nur
umgedreht also ich bin auch ein bisschen
nervös aber ich glaube es klappt ich bin
da ganz zuversichtlich
okay das hat schon mal gut funktioniert
und jetzt einfach das Backpapier ich
nehme erstmal hinten ab oh hinten hätte
ich ruhig ein bisschen besser kühlen
können sich gerade aber es ist ja unser
hinten und da guckt eigentlich keiner
hin das heißt wichtiger ist dass es
vorne schön glatt ist und das haben wir
gerade schon gesehen zack fertig so nun
gucken
ja doch ich finde es echt süß ach doch
ist schon süß und jetzt würde ich bei
mir jetzt hier irgendwie noch so noch
mal was elegantes fehlen ich habe jetzt
hier einfach Goldpulver natürlich
essbaren Glitzer und dann nehme ich
jetzt einfach meine mein Pinsel und
das müsste es eigentlich funktionieren
indem ich hier sowas mache
oh sehr schön
oh doch gefällt mir richtig gut so ein
bisschen verteilen ja und deswegen
eigentlich haben wir das dann unsere
Torte für dieses Jahr
[Musik]
richtig schön ehrlich boah in diesem
goldenen Punkt
ich glaube das ist die schönste ehrlich
so toll
und du
also ist jetzt ein ein typisch
arabisches Gewand das ist ein Frauen
ja ich bin kein Chef also Kiki
zum ersten Mal dafür bin ich ein
bisschen
Boden Buttercreme und lemonte diese sind
von der Süße her also ein bisschen mehr
als sonst aber
okay das ist Datteln reingemixt worden
nein nein
wirklich aus und wenn ich mir das eher
nicht ja genau
aber wenn es vorbei sein sollte danke an
alle geguckt haben danke an dich
jahrelang zu schauen
und kommentieren gerne und es gibt auch
noch weiter also
bis zum nächsten Mal jetzt haben
tschüss
ja das meiste blau ist schon weg
[Musik]